fans watched soldier boy jock on his
haters and butcher finally get his
long-awaited battle against homelander
throw in the most guilt-inducing feast
of seafood ever shown on screen and the
new season of the boys went above and
beyond here are the most eye-opening
scenes from the boys season three
in season three's opening episode
payback the audience witnesses a truly
novel act of lovemaking in the scene
termite has the time of his life at a
party doing all sorts of things that
would most certainly not result in a
clean urine sample however the fun
doesn't stop there as termite finds a
partner who wants the full unabridged
experience of his superpowers remember
the briefly popular thanos theory that
the mcu big bad could have been defeated
if ant-man had simply shrunk down
climbed up thanos's rear end and
returned to his normal size well
presumably the writers of the boys were
inspired by this grotesque visual when
they wrote the scene where termite and
one of his new friends have an explosive
physical encounter the soup shrinks down
to size and then climbs inside his
partner's
orifice the tingly escapade sends
shivers down the partner's spine as he
encourages termite to go further and hit
the right spot unfortunately the
foreplay turns into a bloody mess as
termites sneezes and transforms back to
his regular size by doing so he destroys
his partner's love gun and a good part
of his insides as well if thados ever
comes back to the mcu ant-man should be
taking notes
thanos happened and i got stuck in there
in the episode the only man in the sky
billy butcher becomes the very thing he
despises most a soup he has a reason
though he rationalizes taking v24 a new
type of compound v would help him stand
a chance against gunpowder when butcher
meets soldier boy's former sidekick
again he has super strength and heat
vision in a scene that could be straight
out of an r-rated cut of a superhero
film butcher doesn't just defeat
gunpowder instead he pounds gunpowder's
face to a bloody pulp and then slices
him in half with his heat vision more
importantly the scowl on his face shows
that he doesn't regret his actions for
one second
who is the man behind the mask that's a
question that the boys fans have had
about the silent but violent member of
the seven black noir he never takes off
his helmet ensuring he remains one of
the most intriguing enigmas in superhero
television that is until season 3's
episode barbary coast in a flashback
showing president ronald reagan's off
the books project operation charlie
black noir is shown as a member of the
payback team standing alongside the
likes of soldier boy and crimson
countess however the biggest revelation
comes when the youngstan edgar speaks
with black noir for the first time the
enigmatic superhero shows his face black
noir looks like a normal young guy and
he vents about how no one knows who he
is under the mask later in the episode
noir's face is horribly mutilated
following an ambush on the base but a
few episodes later we find out that
amidst the skirmish payback betrayed
soldier boy to give him to the russians
and a fight against soldier boy would
explain why one of the deadliest
superheroes of the seven was so visibly
injured
the deep shows his love for his aquatic
friends extends beyond caring for the
ocean in season 3 he develops a
particularly close relationship with a
sentient octopus named timothy the
dastardly homelander knows everyone's
secrets though in a twisted show of
who's in charge and how he'll destroy
someone both physically and
psychologically the psychopath serves
seafood to his guests including the
still alive timothy the octopus the deep
is instantly taken aback staring at his
friend on the plate before him with
everyone around him watching and waiting
for the deep to prove his loyalty to
homelander he's forced to eat timothy
alive the event traumatizes the aquatic
soup who can't believe what he's done to
his friend wasn't that delicious
the boys season 3 does a good job of
building up the arrival of soldier boy
while the audience sees him in
flashbacks the extent of his power is
really shown in the episode the last
time to look on this world of lies if
there was any doubt that he was as
powerful as homelander the explosive
scene at crimson county's trailer puts
that doubt to rest soldier boy is now
awake and seeking out crimson countess
for revenge after finding out that she
wasn't paid to betray him and did it
only because she hated him he becomes
enraged
his chest starts to glow as his anger
boils over a massive blast erupts out of
him burning down the trailer and turning
crimson countess into a flame grilled
corpse despite the damage and
destruction done soldier boy walks away
from the wreckage unscathed and
unbothered the boys showrunner eric
kripke explained to variety the
reasoning behind why soldier boy
received his specific set of powers we
said what would be the scariest thing to
homelander and the scariest thing in the
whole world to homelander is just to be
a regular dude so giving soldier boy
these blasts of sort of radioactive
walking chernobyl power that are frying
the compound v out of soup systems is
going to make him very very scary to
homelander
a train experiences a topsy-turvy arc in
the boys season 3. he has moments when
one believes he may see the light and
turn his back on homelander but there
are plenty of occasions that remind us
he still has a long way to go on the
road toward redemption one of his most
important scenes in season three
involves him gaining revenge on the
racist soup bluehawk who viciously
assaulted and crippled his brother
nathan earlier in the season at the hero
gasm event aetrain confronts his
brother's attacker an exchange briefly
takes place before a train grabs hold of
bluehawk and dishes out punishment he
speeds through the streets dragging his
adversary across the asphalt giving him
a serious exfoliation treatment
unsurprisingly blue hawk is nothing more
than roadkill by the end of this super
speed sprint atrian's vengeance isn't
without consequence though as he suffers
a heart attack in the middle of the
street after using his powers and in a
sick twist of fate he now has the heart
of bluehawk
literally
since the boys debuted on amazon fans
have waited for the inevitable clash
between butcher and homelander
unfortunately everyone knows that
homelander's powers coupled with his
psychopathic nature give him the
advantage in almost every situation in
season 3 however butcher has an ace up
his sleeve in fairness it's actually two
the first is v24 the new compound which
gives him temporary superpowers and
evens the playing field
boy
the second is soldier boy a soup who
might be more powerful than homelander
in the episode herogasm butcher and
homelander finally get to slug it out
butcher though doesn't come alone with
the help of soldier boy and huey they
subdue homelander and nearly destroy him
before he escapes in the nick of time
the apple doesn't fall too far from the
tree does it in the boys season 3 it
should have been expected that
homelander and soldier boy would have
some kind of close connection especially
considering their similar powers and
questionable behavior however no one
expected the shocker that soldier boy
drops on homelander the groundwork for
this revelation begins when mindstorm
tells soldier boys something before
dying at the time it's unclear what the
news could be since soldier boy doesn't
give too much away and continues as his
usual prickly self however at the end of
the episode here comes a candle to light
you to bed soldier boy picks up the
phone and calls homelander he doesn't
dance around the topic too much
detailing how he gave a genetic sample
to vaught in the 1980s that he thinks
was used to create homelander if they
just kept me around
i'd have let you take the spotlight
what father wouldn't want that for his
son
soldier boy wasn't a nice guy in the
past nor is he any better now while
butcher believed he could use him as a
weapon to exterminate homelander once
and for all he and the rest of the boys
quickly discover that he has no
intentions of becoming a hero instead
he's ready for carnage and destruction
much like his test tube bouncing baby
boy in the finale of the boys season 3
everyone needs to work together to put a
stomp to this captain america wannabe
the last stand sees mother's milk
butcher and starlight using everything
they've got against soldier boy one on
one it is shown that they can't take him
down or even compete against him but
they have a chance as a team eventually
huey realizes that he'll never be as
powerful as starlight and needs to
support her instead of trying to protect
her he increases the brightness of the
lights in the room powering up her
abilities and this enables starlight to
blast soldier boy with such ferocity and
power that it sends him reeling
if there's one person who has been put
through the ringer in the boys season 3
it's queen maeve she shows her cards
early in the season when she tries to
give butcher the ammunition he needs to
take down homelander when she's captured
many fans assume that homelander got rid
of her after discovering her betrayal
however maeve shows up in the finale in
a heroic manner and ends up having one
of the most significant moments of the
season after soldier boy finds himself
beaten his chest begins to glow
indicating that he's about to blow
everyone up queen maeve who has already
lost an eye at this point bravely
tackles him and they sail out of a
window she doesn't let go of him as he
erupts and engulfs her in the blast to
the world maeve is now dead however it's
revealed that she survived the incident
at the cost of her powers and plans to
take on a new soup-free identity
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single
one you